so what was the favorite thing you guys
bought them that's a good question easy
day for you yeah instinctively I want to
say like I mean I think it's a good it's
a sorted but I think the most
interesting figure and like coolest one
I'm glad I bought was maybe the Akira
Wan which I thought was so fun or the
leave I want Mike Wazowski though the
name of the character should be sad
kendo and oh yeah
that's a good deal I think my favorite
is definitely the job oh that's that's
because it's so unique
I love unique figures yeah yeah there's
so many figures that look alike and who
doesn't like job exactly yeah I just
that's gonna that it's just gonna look
good
yeah what is okay what's the worst
figure you think each of us bought this
is this thing what the hell I don't know
actually I liked all the figurines I
bought maybe that's why I what's the
worst Piggy thing I bought but what's on
you boy I mean you bought so many a car
yeah
that's what yes probably they all you're
[ __ ] a Montague a tree one that's
kind of excuse you trash tasty I do see
you wonder small mind I have a
registered weapon now